-Our next guest
is an Emmy-nominated actress
and one of my favorite peopl
on Earth.
Please welcome to the show
Maya Rudolph, everybody.
-Hi, Seth!
-Oh.
Oh, Maya, hi.
-I know. It's been so long
How are you doing?
-Are you, um -- Are you
not wearing, um, uh --
-Pants?
I've seen everybody doing that
old thing, that old chestnut
I put pants on this morning,
so it's not like --
-Gotcha. Gotcha.
-No pants.
-[ Laughs ] Maya --
Maya, you look good.
I think a lot of people
are worried that, you know, uh
those of us aren't
keeping it together here,
but you seem to be doing
a really good job.
-I'm doing great.
-Yeah.
-I'm doing great. You know
I mean, I'm doing great.
I feel like -- I feel like
I really have this thing,
like, locked down now.
Like, I'm handling it, you know,
in the best way possible.
And I'm -- I feel really good.
I feel really --
I feel really together.
Um, and, uh, yeah, yeah,
things couldn't be better.
I-I've been drinking
a lot of celery.
-Juice? Celery juice, Maya
-I think that's
what it is, yeah.
-Are you -- I think about people
like you during times like this,
Maya, because you've got
four kids living under one roof.
-I do have four kids, yeah
And people, you know --
People have been asking me
a lot, "How do you do it all?"
And I'm like...
"You're looking at it."
-[ Laughs ] Yeah. Yeah.
And so you're not
falling to pieces at all?
-I mean, eh, you know, som
things fall through the cracks
I mean, I'm not --
You know, I'm not a perfect --
I'm not a perfect mom,
but, I mean, I brush my teeth,
you know?
-That's good.
-But I think we're incredibl
lucky to be healthy,
so I feel like that's all
that matters, you know?
-You have a new animated fil
on Netflix
called "The Willoughbys."
-Yes.
-This is based on a book.
Did you -- Was this a book
you read to your kids?
-Seth, can you see me like -
I'm seeing myself right now.
Can you see, like,
below my chin?
-Yeah, we're a little bit wide
than just your head, yeah.
-I'll be right back.
I forgot something on the stove.
-[ Laughing ]
Hey.
-Oh, there we go.
-Sorry about that.
Ohh. Sorry about that.
-Oh, that's fine.
-I was baking.
-So, this is, uh --
You're in an animated film
called "The Willoughbys"
that is on Netflix.
This is based
on a children's book.
Was it a book that you had rea
to your children?
-Actually, my oldest daughte
was reading the book on her own.
She -- Before I ended up
doing the movie, she actuall
just found it on her own
through her school librarian
It was really sweet,
and she was telling me
about this
really interesting book.
And, you know,
if I had my glasses on,
I'd be able to tell you
the author's name.
-[ Laughs ]
I think you might --
Maya, I think if you just
look up, I think you might -
-I just realized
I have my glasses on. Okay
I got to be honest
with you, Seth.
Um, I'm a little stressed out.
-Yeah.
-But like I said,
I feel like we're really lucky
so I have nothing
to complain about.
But I, uh --
I haven't, um --
I haven't, uh, you know...
bathed in a while.
-You haven't bathed in a while
Yeah.
-Yeah.
-Is it one of those things -
Because you look very clea
on camera.
Would I be able to tell
if we were in the same room?
-Yeah.